on va on va se retrouver seul instant
pour le début de tout chemin on passe il
y aura de manière à la télé il y aura
alors je vous dis le retour du un pour
tous tous pour un avec les gars jouent
nous l'a réclamé c'est le retour
aujourd'hui le come back est pour le
moment
gilles verdez qui est de retour dans
l'émission gilles verdez avant gilles
verdez les chéris c'était sa tt s'agit
bien hier dans l'émission je lui ai
promis de le relooker parce que voilà je
pense qu'il a un énorme potentiel mais
quand je veux dire à potentiel c'est
vraiment un potentiel qui peut faire que
demain et gilles verdez soit dans les
10-15 sex-symbol planétaire vous
attendez les gars vous entendez bien
alors alors je vous le dis je vais
demander à mes deux assistants stylisme
de venir me rejoindre pour aider à
relooker j'ai bien d'allumer de
l'assistance y lycée nature matthieu
delormeau qui fait son retour
aujourd'hui
merci merci qui va relancer les bratisla
boys ouais et guillaume genton guilloton
à qui on a on n'inventera rien tu peux
dire aux téléspectateurs
je t'ai tout appris au niveau du site
bien sûr je suis ton conseiller style et
moi visagiste et voilà exactement je
suis conseiller stylisme des sportifs
exacte du sport avec moi voilà je vous
le dis et regardez c'est costaud ok les
chéris gilles verdez j'ai déjà des idées
gilles on va avoir exactement je vous le
dis on va lancer un chrono bah on va
avoir deux minutes pour la wii
tourtereaux loup qui adore d'accord
d'accord d'accord
gilles thoreau look je vais demander à
mes équipes à mes équipes de stylisme
déjà de proposer des chaussées légère et
6 et attention vous avez déjà des idées
il va falloir leur habillée de la tête
aux pieds en début a également les
chaussures et que c'était là vous allez
nous dire si vous préférez gilles verdez
comme ça où gilles verdez comme il va
être dans un instant il y aura bien sûr
le jury un jury de professionnels du
style oui regardez vous voulez pas vous
planter voilà qui sera là pour juger
vous aussi chez vous vous avez jugé à sa
hashtag gilles verdez pas y jeter des
bébés déjà comment ne rien faire sur le
physique
on sent que tout misé sur les frags leur
attention pas de dénigrement on ne
devine repart non le sujet un esprit
guillaume genton qu'est ce t'en penses
quoi on attend quelque chose de très
cajole casual meanstream d'accord c'est
quoi tes conneries ça c'est la mode ce
que tu connais pas ben voilà c'est quoi
alors est ce que tu peux tu que tu payes
cash in ce que tu veux faire bouger tant
le look de 2021
pour gilles wafi match et c'est un loupé
de 2004 nous dit le mec qui a la gueule
de vincent lagaf alors voilà quelque
chose de très coloré un peu bling bling
j'adore les couleurs mais il adore les
couleurs attention les chaînes j'ai dit
et je mettrai ma touche personnelle
d'accord les chais mieux on a deux
minutes pour le relooker de la tête
attention alors là ça fait trop ces
projets laissés dulin c'est peu mais pas
tous pour l'instant attendant les ainsi
que tu proposes c'est vulgaire ça
j'aurais bien mis sa non mais ça va je
me mette une chemise en ce moment c'est
toi qui ont loupé c'est moi parce que
sinon tu sais où tu le fais toi c'est
moi le chef looking non c'est pour le
coup de feu d'un mais qui rate une
minute va
mais ça non mais c'est true blood et
rassure le risque évalué m on va lui
mettre une veste colorée
ce à quoi ça nous irait très bien mais
qui connaît rien là-dessus minutes c'est
super c'est un dentiste
l'accusé nié tout ça avec lui
oui oui oui les maires des villes
séparées du futur médecin s'est retrouvé
là il faut trouver ça s'est très vite il
reste quarante secondes les mecs aux
arrêts pas jamais ça on sera quand même
très chic ça c'est chic ça c'est cher
mais c'est quoi votre soirée quand il
est comme ça
non trop soit non les mecs vite vite
vite mais ce noir labarthe ne dit jamais
plus de deux couleurs mises à ce séjour
c'est je te dis c'est pas ça je lis ça
ça s'appelle rouge
est-ce qu'on va te demanderont pourquoi
il s'est compliqué j'ai vite sont les
puciers benaissa n'a par ailleurs pas
pardon il m'a saisi
non on n'en fait pas trop axé ses
limites du miel sur la tête de ma mère
qui les frais de valores on va voir dans
un instant la ville du public est ce que
vous le préférez eymétois côté mais toi
que tu es toi mais toi que des toits
regarder sans rigoler il est 100 fois
plus sérieux là mais vraiment un boulot
je suis sérieux mes frères ont fait
tomber des choses une guerre non non non
c'est un problème avec lui c'est pas
nouveau mathieu aussi ces nouveaux
bateaux non non non écoute moi bien mais
la passe pour doublons dans l'émission
sache le faire par match et mené à la
première